E aí
[Música]
o
primeiro desafio de um desenhista
Conseguiu quebrar sua bicicleta tá
garantido tá tudo certo gente eu queria
contar para vocês a história de crianças
que gostam de desenhar e daquele de
insanos que acha que é possível mudar o
mundo com amor
e que o único campo de concentração seja
nossa liberdade eu vou contar para você
essa criança que vocês estão vendo aqui
nesse dia ela pegou uma caixa de papel
uma caixa de papelão e achou que podia
fazer um tanque de guerra para lutar
pelo meio ambiente
e essa criança que tá aqui eu vou contar
pra você
e ela tem o mesmo medo que eu tenho
agora e tem a mesma coragem que eu tenho
agora
essa criança que tá aqui ganhou isso
aqui
e nesse dia um pato de madeira um troféu
te falou assim para mim vai acredito que
está fazendo tá tudo certo mas é um papo
de madeira esse troféu um símbolo para
mim nesse dia
Michele assistindo aqui que já deu sorte
antes
e nesse dia com incrível vai nesse dia
tá eu tinha medo eu tinha coragem e
decidiu também perdi muito como vocês
podem ver
e de lá para casa criança perdeu muita
coisa mas ganhou coragem de entender as
metáforas da devastação né isso é
importante
e a
e nessa metáfora de entender devastação
eu me torno um cartunista e um
cartunista tá sempre dando privilégio
das desgraças para o torto para o
desarmonioso para o feio porque talvez o
professor ali no sócio não falaria de A
beleza do feio
e o cartucho não tá preocupado com
Ostentação do ser bonito e Está mais
interessado em saber a verdade por trás
o que parece desarmônico isso é
sensacional isso me motivava
é como se tentasse buscar nossas três
palavras o sentido do meu desenho
é o de Sam com metáfora de destino que é
muito parecido com que a bike faz o
Rastro que a gente percorre o da sign
como modo de ser também parecido com a
bike que é o jeito que a gente se
relaciona quando tava correndo eu
prefiro devagar eu prefiro curtindo as
árvores como é que eu preciso tá esse
lugar que tipo de traçado eu faço com a
minha bike a gente me traçado eu faço
meu desenho
Oi e o design como interciência e traz
significado para gente
Oi gente de longe para descobrir isso a
gente Valoriza as vezes a capela Sistina
o era eu essa eurocentres ação da arte e
a gente tem aqui no Brasil em Ouro Preto
Minas Gerais o mestre Ataíde que
trabalhou com Aleijadinho um cara que
traz um Barroco essa busca pelo
significado do que tá fazendo essa força
da metáfora dos pontos de significado
é engraçado que essa arte que tá lá em
Ouro Preto quatro quadras para o lado a
gente essa imagem aqui
que vocês verem nessa imagem
e essa imagem cada grupo cada gesto
representa a dor de uma criança de 12
anos e que nessa época varia 500 gramas
de ouro
e essa dor expressa a exploração do
Brasil desde o começo o modo de seda
essa existência era de dor
e nessa escavação interna da queria
compartilhar com vocês pessoas que
mudaram meu caminho pessoas que eu fui
conhecendo estudando sentido até para o
meu desenho a primeira delas é a
professora dali professor de Filosofia e
da nossa universidade em Curitiba EA dar
nesse dia me falou seguinte tava eu só
passei a ter noção da minha deficiência
o dia que eu cheguei na escola apontavam
para mim falava assim olha lá vem a mãe
tinha 17 anos só dali passou havia sua
própria deficiência nesse dia pelo olhar
dos outros e eu como ilustrador que
queria sempre Inter fácil então rolando
fiz essa tira que usualmente é uma
representação do tempo o recado que
vende daquele momento
é a segunda pessoa a irmã Mônica alguém
que ia eu diria uma interface entre a
universidade EA comunidade a gente vive
Eduardo nossa universidade em contraste
muito forte uma relação muito bonito com
a Vila Torres e tem essa característica
de agente de transformação para uma
Mônica que a gestora do lado das irmãs
vicentinas tem como modo de existência
fazer essa troca entre a universidade
EA comunidade
nesse dia a gente tava com os alunos
pintando os personagens do Entorno para
dentro da horta essa horta orgânica
alimentar 120 crianças filhos de
coletores de material reciclável
e a terceira pessoa também da Vila
Torres com quem tem uma relação
interessante é a Cauana Batista O que
que a Cauana fazia ela pegava os livros
de crianças de coletores de rua vinha
nos carrinhos e via que as crianças
estavam no entorno sem ter que fazer e
une os dois pegava as crianças por ali
dentro sua casa dela ela começou mal MG
chamado o dph organização para o
desenvolvimento e potencial humano e era
uma referência dessa transformação que
existe por meio do desenho nesse dia a
gente também desenhava os alunos que
estavam na hora de PH para parte externa
é a quarta pessoa é uma menina chamada
Beatriz
a Bia tem 8 anos e ela na Amazônia
enquanto a gente faz um projeto com mais
de 70 designers do mundo todo ela ficou
durante três semanas só rondando a gente
e ela ficava ouvindo fica ouvindo e
depois de três semanas ela chegou para a
gente e falou assim olha deixa eu
mostrar para vocês o que eu fiz e ela
trouxe essa caixinha
medicinal com as ervas que ela tinha
aprendido com a mãe e com a vó que
curavam dor de joelho dor de cabeça dor
de barriga se inscrever um texto era só
imagem lindo poder de abertura que
existe nessa menina muitas vezes no
design gente se apropria dessa desse
processo criativo dessa abertura eu falo
meus alunos é esse número é ruim sem
medo e eu mesma que tô cheio de menos
com eles de não errar né
eu voltei da Amazônia vou dar uma olhada
nas fotos no céu fiz na minha Ostentação
no Meu Ego inflado olhe para essa foto e
entra em conflito
primeiro por justamente Ostentar esse
sentido de empoderamento achando que eu
superior Branco privilegiado chegaria lá
e ensinaria aquela comunidade e eu me
sinto ignorante por não conhecer a
cultura do nordeste do Norte brasileiro
do Cuidado que esses ribeirinhos tem
algum nos outros a da relação que ele
tem com a natureza
Ah e por me sentir também num corpo de
um colonizador o Biotipo de um
estrangeiro Nutella comunidade isso
refletiu para mim muito forte eu fui
queria entender qual era a essência do
meu desenho o meu desenho com outra
metáfora de caminho que eu percebi
eu vou entender origem da minha família
na comunidade bregante no norte da
Itália
no período em que geram muitos italianos
e europeus de lá entre 1890 de 1930 essa
migração humana que ainda hoje existe e
a gente tem muitos países têm
dificuldade em aceitar sua ligação tá
e junto com essa galera vem o meu bisavô
César meu bisavô cézanne o meu bisa com
todos os preconceitos que ele tinha como
a visão muitas vezes alienada assista
porque não fascista
resolvi até a Bela ideia em Garibaldi no
momento que os europeus se instale a dá
o nome do primeiro filho Talvez o pior
desenho do mundo
se alguém que marcou por traços
braços de a judeus
alguém que traz no locausto nosso pior
imagético Nossa Pior ideia já feito até
hoje
se alguém que por meio do desenho fez
esse cartunista dentro de uma prisão
dentro de um campo de concentração
criar desenhos de metáforas com os
alimentos quando eu que estavam vivendo
na época me pergunta até hoje se os
soldados achado Isso legal e não
entendiam as metáforas não entende os
códigos esses desenhos
e eu tô falando de alguém tem assinatura
aqui que tava a gente não conhece
talvez você já tem um se ligado eu tô
falando de Adolf Hitler e Hitler foi o
nome que recebeu meu avô
O Hitler era meu avô
o
Antônio Monte Matilde
e ele Parece um galã aqui né mas lá em
casa a gente não podia chamar meu avô
pelo nome eu vou contar porque na escola
eu tinha que sempre evitar o que era o h
ponto Antônio eu nunca pude abraçar meu
vô
E aí
e ele não tinha um dedo e tende a mão
com distância para que a gente quisesse
cumprimentar ele era um cara que tinha
muita dificuldade de saber se expressar
e entender os próprios sentimentos e lá
em casa e isso era um acordo quando fui
prender mais tarde na escola Quem era
isso que eu passei entender com mais
propriedade toda aquela dificuldade que
meu voltinha de expressão e de ele mesmo
se entender
e a esse no cenário que o dia meu vô oi
Mirela torneiro mecânico então é sempre
uma coisa muito agressiva cheio de
ruídos ele tava sempre com essa máscara
e para mim parecia um guerreiro um
alquimista que transformava toda aquela
dor e peões de metal e eu sabia que
depois de uma grande sol de uma Faísca
ou que ele pediu para me afastar ele ia
vir pequeno piãozinho de metal e eu fui
percebendo mais velho que meu vou usar
esses pequenos gestos como forma de ele
se aproximar da gente então eu conto
meus irmãos e eu fui entendendo com meu
vô que ele usava arte para se expressar
mais tarde quando ele soube que eu
passei para faculdade de desenho de
design ele me deu uma bicicleta ia vim
de bicicleta até hoje da aula então
esses símbolos ficam a gente né meu vô
Hitler também queria ser artista como
retorno ruim que a gente conhece e
analisando em São desenhos no meu vô dos
anos 80 e eu não questiona nem a
qualidade desses desenhos Mas eu sou
apaixonado pela intencionalidade em
analisar como eu vou escolhi essas
figuras era Jesus nessa visão ainda
ocidental que a gente tem o Papa e Nossa
Senhora e eu acho muito bonito pensar
aqui meu vô Talvez se tivesse criando
uma meta-narrativa dele mesmo uma
possibilidade de sublevação dele se
olhar e por meio do desenho saber que
ele tinha um certo sossego assim na
própria não compreensão do nome
e eu me torno desenhista sonho também do
meu avô o pai meu bisavô dizer que não
aceitava vou trabalhar com crianças no
bairro do Tatuquara aqui em Curitiba e
nessa foto a gente tá usando os pratos
com o tema da exposição que era fome
Oi e esse menino que tá bem no centro
ele virou um dos grandes ilustradores
hoje no Brasil trabalha no maior estúdio
ilustração brasileira que o estúdio Copa
e esse menino achou por meio do desenho
o seu modo de série e o seu significado
Oi e esse menino se chama Jesus é o nome
judeu e para mim é muito bonita que
parece fazer muito sentido poder falar
que um professor Neto de Hitler
aprende o é transformado por um aluno
que tem o nome entendeu
e eu espero que cada um de nós por mais
que todo entorno esteja ruim As pessoas
só se o julgamento de você que você
consiga transformar todas as suas dores
por meio da sua expressão e um desenho
que mude o mundo
Muito obrigado
E aí